yeah welcome to this video playing a
five-minute game against Grandmaster I
think this real name right should I of
him he's gotten really high rating here
27 27 something Wow ok the Pantheon II
and I'd like to see what he's playing
against d5 in those two points yani
games recently in the bike they didn't
play d 5 I don't know why d 5 is simply
simply fine for black it leads them it
should be should be a I mean okay if
this is a transposition to the Goering
gambit all black can play other moves
like this I don't even need to to go for
the Goering takes I'm Bishop g4 okay no
I can play a long castle to maybe
question is way too just second just a
second
should I well let's let's cancel on
yes but
a queen a fire for it's a bit like
Scandinavian but with with some twists
of course orders check first yeah let's
give the check first
of course this is solved it all very
tactical it probably needs to cancel now
d 594 looks like black is winning
basically castles I probably need to
take and take on d4 this is of course
very difficult to assess iam why is
there something else in night 95 oh very
very crazy position maybe 95
95 Quincy to Bishop f3 it was being
really sick cancels yeah okay I need to
take it and what now we have probably
take before him winning upon but it's
not clear what what are the implications
of all this okay I cannot go back now no
way if I take it d for now at least I'm
threatening something he cannot be half
the specialist hanging takes Queen tags
and I mean that may need to take with
the rookie I'm if I take with the Queen
he can exchange of play Bishop b2 and
then I'm toast on g7 so probably here
and now I'm attacking the Queen and if
he goes to a four I can grab it to where
he needs to yeah he needs to learn to
take care of the material yeah this is
certainly not bad for black but still
are not easy to play just Knight f6 from
the end to get my pieces out yes 2d 787s
hanging
and now this is a possibility Queen a 70
should I go be six if it takes Queen B
seven or something or they can they can
go back with the Queen yeah probably
just this muscle down let's sign yeah
what has got some compensation may be at
least on a blitz game maybe maybe in
general but so a bit double shake am can
play oh when it is the so dangerous
Queen 87 I thought we should be for
about Queen a7s estimating the full made
threat maybe maybe it'd be 628 a3 Bishop
before Jack oh I forgot about that okay
it's probably not not so dramatic
there should be special p IM cake and ok
I thought I know I don't have that
actually I have forgotten I forgot about
this oops what I don't understand stand
what's going on here why couldn't you
take p6
check
Jack Queen g6
hi I don't tell me I have lost yeah yeah
it's not open to can't believe that he
just Melendez and it's sometimes crazy
this game it's not even a draw yeah
unbelievable
yeah of course I'm down to three seconds
so it doesn't matter really Jack Queen
III is major yeah okay he doesn't see
the mate in one yeah but of course it's
okay it doesn't matter you win some time
yeah yes I don't understand anything
about chess where it doesn't he take p6
now I'm what
I we should be set me up should be seven
was my plan but yeah of course if it
takes the Queen attack is it take his
queen so it is not working after all
yeah idiotic so I'm just winning here
for nothing but I was so irritating so
irritated okay um I of course everything
winsford known the Queen D sixes of
course bed I intended Roxy 3e but ok
this is now draw and Knight b6 is the
drawn out of course because f3 yeah 20
seconds and I was a bit too to confuse
any way by now I really wonder sometimes
what people are doing I don't understand
anything you think he had really nice
compensation and
yeah this wasn't working just take with
the pawn and it's interesting I mean
interesting white should be should be
much better I forgot that that did this
is immediately hanging and I thought
Bishop b4 Queenie for Queen takes Queen
B seven or something but of course it
can take immediately before that it's I
don't know unclear but of course this is
just clearly better for black but ok
it's blitz chess it's not I cannot play
perfectly here I mean the computer gives
rook 26 with the clear advantage group
g6 even coming ok this is normally move
and now it's it's a bit tricky already
yeah but what should I cannot account of
tank life for a minute and then find
rook t six years eve at all yeah up to
six is strong i understand Bishop e3
roxy 6m it's very embarrassing
yeah what the Pantheon is just justice
just a strange opening I really don't
know why why people are playing it and I
didn't understand this invite also Queen
85 here by the way is winning for black
you we should be to Queen B 6 to pawn
saying yeah okay not what can you do and
where will i blundered to this Queen d6
stuff here otherwise it would still be
still be a draw I winning of not winning
if I don't allow that just play some
other mousse queen of six and b6 is
hanging f3 is still hanging he doesn't
have a Ruth but ok I was so down on time
because of the complications that I then
I didn't didn't find it yeah thanks for
watching